(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- All right, we've got
time for one last story.
And it's all about hope and
the power of human connection.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
This month marked 21 years
since the worst terrorist
attack on our nation.
Like so many of us,
a third grade teacher in
Illinois felt helpless
after the attacks on 9/11.
She wanted to help her students
and kids in New York City heal.
So she had her class write letters,
and she sent them
to a random third grade
classroom in New York.
That led to a year long pen pal program,
but there was no way back
then she could have known
it would also lead to a
decades long friendship
and now a new book.
We have that teacher on the line right now
along with the teacher
from the New York class.
Everybody say hello to Elaine and Julie.
Hello.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hi ladies.
So first of all, thank you
so much for being teachers.
You are angels amongst us.
I love teachers so much.
You are just selfless
people, and I appreciate you.
So I just wanted to say that first.
But also, tell us about those-
- Thank you so much.
- Absolutely.
Tell us about those first letters though
and what grew from there.
- Well, after 9/11,
most Americans wanted
to do something to help.
And we adults could donate
money, we could do blood drives.
But when you're eight and nine years old,
you really are limited
in what you could do.
But I knew my students
could probably write letters
that would show that they cared.
And I took those letters to
the Yorkville Post Office.
And the clerk there
picked out a random
zip code for Manhattan,
put it on the envelope,
and it was addressed to
any third grade class.
And we had no clue
whether they would be
delivered or received.
- Wow. And Julie, how
did you end up with them?
- Well, out of all the
third grade teachers
in all of New York City,
the letters ended up in my mailbox,
which was amazing chance.
And it was really one
of the sweetest things
that anyone could have done at the time.
And after we excitedly wrote back,
we started a year long relationship
where the classes exchanged
drawings and holiday cards.
And also, Elaine got to visit my class.
And I got to visit Elaine's class.
And we started what became
a 21 year friendship.
- That is so cool, y'all.
And now-
(audience applauding)
Now you've written
a book called the United
States of Friendship.
So why did you wanna write that?
- Well, there's been a whole
generation born since 9/11.
And they don't have a clue
about all of the good things that happened
out of something so bad.
And so I wrote to Julie
and asked her if she was willing
to tell our story again in a book form.
And she agreed.
And so we wrote it as a conversation
about the actual events that
happened to us at that time.
And I wrote my memories in red ink,
and she wrote hers in blue.
We finished our book at
the end with the phrase
our unity is our strength.
And when we come together
as a united country,
that's when we really are the strongest.
- Oh, I love this.
Thank you so much, Elaine.
Thank you, Julie.
(crowd applauding)
(crowd cheering)
This is amazing-
- Thank you.
- sharing this with all of us.
I'm liking your post right now, alright?
(bell dinging)
- [Elaine] Yay.
- And that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1000.
That's $500 each.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(woman laughing)
- Oh, wow.
- Oh my gosh.
Thank you. That's amazing.
- Thank you.
- Thank you ladies.
(crowd applauding)
Thank you so much for being educators.
Thank you for joining us,
and thank you to all our guests today,
Billy Eichner, Luke McFarland-
(audience applauding)
Jim Rash, Simone Press, and Carley.
Y'all have a great day.
If its not, try and change it.
(audience applauding)